and we're going to have now a panel
addressing the question of whether we
should fear or welcome the coming
singularity or indeed whether it will
come so may I welcome the panelists for
that we have as magnetars moderator
maggie Bowden you've already met this
morning and then we have Ray Kurzweil
who you know Harry Shum who is vice
president for research at Microsoft Max
tegmark from MIT and the future of life
Institute max flex video and Stuart
Russell from Berkeley so Maggie over to
you okay well hello again everybody
what is the singularity it's an idea
it's the supposed point at which
artificial intelligence will not only
reach but actually surpass human
intelligence and thereby become able to
make itself even better and the idea is
that after that time most of these
science certainly the exciting science
will be done by AI much of the art will
be done by AI and the problems of not
only myths and but government
international politics anything really
will be taken over certainly helped
perhaps taken over by AI now this is a
hugely controversial idea people
disagree very much about whether it
could happen they disagree about whether
it will happen they disagree as you've
just heard in the question time about
whether it might sorry when it might
happen and they disagree very much about
whether it would be a bad or a good
thing and that's what we're going to be
focusing on should we welcome it or
should we fear it and Ray's going to
kick us off I suspect Ray he's going to
say that bad laws we should welcome it
and perhaps the others are going to jump
in and say well
not so fast so let's see what happens
right well I've been accused of being an
optimist before I guess you have to be
an optimist to be an inventor and an
entrepreneur but actually wrote
extensively starting in the 1990s about
the downsides and of course every
technology back to fire has had promise
in peril fire kept us warm cooked our
food we're also burned down our houses
we have much more powerful technologies
today so the promise in parellel are are
much more powerful recently this was a
lot of concern expressed by Stephen
Hawking and Elon Musk and others about
the dire dangers of artificial
intelligence those dangers are real
I wrote a response really along these
lines that first of all we need to
pursue AI we've heard a lot today about
how we're diagnosing disease curing
disease cleaning up the environment
overcoming poverty with artificial
intelligence of the three new
information technologies that are going
to transform the world biotechnology
which I talked about reprogramming agent
software in our bodies nanotechnology
reprogramming materials and artificial
intelligence the one that's actually an
existential risk already is
biotechnology the same technologies
we're using to reprogram biology away
from cancer and disease could also be
used by bioterrorist to create a new
super weapon so this has recognized a
couple of decades ago the industry in
the field developed the so-called
Asilomar guidelines we're now actually
seeing the benefits of biotechnology the
beginning to trickle out this will be a
flood over the next decade so far we've
seen no dangers as max pointed out the
dinner last night that doesn't mean we
can cross it off our concern list was it
was pointed out at dinner that these are
seldom our guidelines are well one side
of the table said they're already
obsolete another part of the table said
well they're about to be obsolete but
that's always the case we have to
recreate these ethical standards in
these technology defense systems that's
actually the biggest challenge
of the 21st century it's how do we reap
the promise which I think we have a
moral imperative to do because it's
still a lot of suffering in the world
while we control the peril the Asilomar
guidelines have worked so far it's a
good blueprint for how we can keep AI
safe but we're going to have to
continually reconsider them and I agree
with max that we need to actually talk
about this now
even though the existential dangers are
still off in the future I do want to go
first um so I think it's worth a
expanding a little further on why one
might think that that better machines
would be a problem so what exactly is
the fear of the singularity and if you
open a newspaper and just page through
it until you find a picture of
Terminator robots taking over the world
and then read that article the the
journalists story is usually that
somehow machines will spontaneously wake
up and you know they'll be in a bad mood
because they just woke up and they'll
hate the human race and they'll try to
kill us all and they'll they'll be armed
obviously because we just go around
arming our computers a lot my laptop has
a machine gun dead so it's not gonna
happen like that the the process is
going to be a little bit like what
happens when when you rub the lamp and
the genie comes out and the genie grants
you three wishes and it's very very
difficult to state the first two wishes
in exactly the right way and in all of
these stories and the story of King
Midas as well you asked for something
and then you realize that you haven't
asked for it quite right and the third
wish is always you know please can you
undo the first two wishes because I
didn't quite say them right I in case of
King Midas it was too late he died of
starvation and thirst because everything
he tried to eat and drink turned into
gold and so it was irreversible and the
the issue that goes has been raised for
many years going back at least to
Norbert Wiener the famous control
theorist in 1960 if you put a purpose
into a machine and that machine is
capable enough that it's going to be
hard to reverse that decision then you
better be sure that the purpose is
exactly the purpose that you desire and
at the moment we don't know how to do
that so it's a technological problem in
much the same way that the containment
of nuclear fusion is a technological
problem and fusion is a source of
unlimited energy that could save our
environment and perhaps even save our
race but it's not useful until it's
contained
and I think artificial intelligence may
have some of the same characteristics
the question that was posed to us here
was should we welcome a singularity or
should we fear it and I agree with both
Ray and do it and saying we should
welcome it and fear it we should welcome
it because every single thing that we
love that I love about civilization
there's a product of intelligence and
obviously if we can amplify our
intelligence thanks machines we can
create a much more wonderful future at
the same time we should fear it because
only if we fear it are we actually going
to take the right precautions and get
things right this is going to be the
most powerful technology ever we don't
want to just bumble into it unprepared
that would be ridiculous and I think you
said something very wise there ray or
you can you mentioned fire in the past
oh we found all technologies to be
double-edged swords of course to give us
new ways of doing good and new ways of
messing up but we've always used a
strategy in the past of learning from
mistakes that's what must change we
learn from mistake with fire we stood up
a bunch of times and now there's a fire
exit there and a fire extinguisher over
there and things are fine but with more
powerful tech like nuclear weapons
synthetic biology and AI we do not learn
from mistakes we want to get things
right the first time because
is perhaps the only time we'll have it
that's why I think it's so valuable to
get away from this thing about us let's
whine about whether we should be worried
we should be and ask what concrete
things can we do now to prepare these
are exciting and challenging research
questions that we don't know the answer
to yet and we want to know the answer to
them so I feel that to be able to
welcome this and feel really optimistic
and excited about the future which I do
we need to win this race between the
growing power of the technology of AI
and the growing wisdom with which you
manage it and so far it's very natural
that the investments have been mainly
into just making the thing work that's
the natural thing to do before there is
much impact on society but now is the
time to also invest in the other kind of
research developing the wisdom figuring
out how we can create not pure
undirected intelligence as you said in
your nice nuclear metaphor but
beneficial artificial intelligence I mix
make some most necessary comments here I
follow what max just said I think before
we worry about should we fear should we
welcome singularity or the AI technology
let's just be a little bit specific you
know what we really mean by AI what are
those things we already developed and we
believe in the next five to 50 years we
will be able to do there are few things
that we generally say they actually are
about AI is this speech this computer
vision is natural language and we also
talk about robots but one thing we don't
talk too much is actually the general
intelligence that general understanding
what's going on it's just very very
difficult to talk about you know did I
say something wrong or something these
kind of general questions I don't really
did the speech for many years you
definitely would agree with me I think
we are only about a few years to several
years away that computer speech
recognition error rates will match human
level we're talking about only a few
years out if you look at a computer
vision in a visual recognition we also
talk about probably somewhere several
years a couple of tens of years we
actually for certain limited areas like
if you have only ten thousands of
categories of objects
you know computers so they can almost do
as well if not slightly better than
human now if you like talk about natural
language we're still far away from
really understanding natural language we
still have problems translating
languages from Swedish to English or to
Chinese
robots are particularly interesting now
if we look at in the robots in let's do
it talked about and you watch the movies
the science fiction's you have robots
running around shoot at us I think
that's probably where we have most of
fear and that's to me it's not really
justified today and as we think about
this what we really need is actually no
spending more investing more and
developing better and the better AI
technologies right now well let me
follow up on the comment about movies
because I think a lot of the fear of AI
comes from the typical future dystopian
movie where it's the AI versus the
humans or there's two groups of humans
fighting for control over the AI we
don't have one or two AIS such as they
are today we have two or three billion
of them projections are well have six
billion smartphones which are AIS
circuit today in the world they're
deeply integrated with us we use them
constantly they're going to become even
more intimately integrated in the future
the primary application is going to be
humans and machines working in very
close concert together so for one thing
I think keeping AI safe we need to keep
humans safe and while the reasons were
distrustful of AI is because we're in
distrustful of humans when you look at
human history but I mean that's the
vision is there's going to be a very
deeply integrated society we're already
a human technological society it's
coming actually from one of the unlock
online audience they say how will they I
be able to cope with the current lack of
development of our ethical and moral
norms how do you put that in
I think that's a that's a great question
so one of the approaches that may be
able to eliminate the risk from from
super intelligent AI is that the
machines have to come to understand what
human values are and they have to learn
that for example if you ask them to cure
cancer a good solution to the problem of
cancer is not to to wipe out the human
race and then there won't be any cancer
anymore alright that's not quite what we
meant to to eliminating cancer you know
limiting human suffering you know you
might say well you know humans are
always going to suffer because that's
just the way they are so we have to you
know I I have to eliminate human
suffering so I have to eliminate humans
so machines have to understand our
values you know more more parochially in
a very very foreseeable future when we
have domestic robots and self-driving
cars they have to be able to make value
judgments and understand the things we
care about so a domestic robot that is
supposed to be preparing dinner for the
kids before the parents get home when
there's nothing in the fridge we don't
want the robot to cook the cat for
dinner not understanding that that the
cat is a very valuable part of the
family it certainly cheap source of meat
but it's not quite the right one so if a
if a machine makes a mistake like that
if a domestic robot does that you can
only imagine what the newspapers will
say and you can only imagine the
reaction of people who might have been
considering buying one of those robots
there's no way I would have a robot in
my house that was capable of doing
something like that so it would wipe out
the industry overnight there's an
enormous ly strong economic incentive
for companies that are building AI to
take these questions very seriously
because otherwise any company any
startup company that that doesn't pay
attention to this could could ruin it
for everybody else so they're going to
have to figure out how to make machines
behave ethically avoid doing things even
if they're told to do something
by their human master they have to know
what's right and wrong so that they
don't do something catastrophic to the
discussion here that human society is
getting more ethical the number of
democracies we had a hundred years ago
you could count on the fingers of one
hand I was certainly not every nation as
a perfect democracy but we've definitely
moved dramatically in that direction
human life it's very harsh and unjust if
you read writers like Thomas Hobbes only
a few centuries ago when human life
expectancy was 37 better communication
technology has led to more democracy
that people think that's surprising that
for example we have the lowest rate of
violence today your chance of being
killed is hundreds of times less than it
was a few centuries ago although max
points out if we ever had an incident
with a nuclear war or abuse of
biotechnology that those statistics
would change quickly but we are we are
making progress the reason we don't
think so is we have exponentially better
information about what's wrong with the
world yeah this question of how to have
get machines to learn human goals and
values is so central to this because of
course as you Maggie mentioned in the
morning panel one way of defining
intelligence is simply how good you are
at accomplishing your goals so a chess
computer is very good at winning in
chess a more general system to be very
good at doing whatever its goals are we
cannot ignore the question of what goals
to give the systems and and right now we
largely have you know when when ante has
Lubitz flew this Germanwings airplane
into the Alps killing all the passengers
AI could have prevented this if the
flight computer had realized that there
is no reasonable reason for why an
airplane should be flown into a mountain
it could have just gone into safe mode
and autopilot to the airport right and
similarly future AI systems we need to
make them such that they can understand
what humans really want not that's what
they say they want and also it's basic
human values if if you ask for it
ask your future self-driving car to take
you to land vet
Airport as fast as possible you're gonna
get there chased by helicopters and
covered in vomit
you're gonna be like no no this isn't
quite what I wanted and your car will be
like this is exactly what you asked for
and you know our children learn very
quickly they'll take us so literally
they understand what we mean when we ask
them for things not so later than the
funny examples you gave with a cat
they're exactly in that same category so
this is this is another one example of a
technical fascinating research problem
how do you make machines able to observe
human behavior figure out what humans
really want and also what the sort of
consensus is among humans about what's a
good thing and the important ethical
question I think always the AI
technology today we must address is
really about the beta is really about
the data privacy and the use of privacy
related to all the data we have the
reason we actually have a lot of AI
today largely reason is because we now
can collect a lot more data it's not
only just about your own data is
actually about the data from so many
people so many you know human AI systems
that we actually have today the reason
we have intelligence better today is
because we have this collective
intelligence that we are able to learn
from each other with all this kind of
power with this kind of data now we have
to be very careful as we design what
kind of systems we have and related to
that is what I actually call the
emotional AI when you design at the Year
system that you actually have to take
care of that okay well there's a lot of
thought there a lot of thought there
going on and will be going on and must
be going on from you youngsters
especially in the audience we're going
to be living with this stuff throughout
your lives and your children too there
really are a lot of very important and
very difficult issues to think about so
thank you ever so much the panel from
raising many of them thank you
you